well I think the changing media
landscape is the an opportunity for new
voices to emerge I think it's become
easier to if you have something powerful
to say that you don't have to go through
gatekeepers anymore you don't need to be
validated by larry king or you know
whoever the editors of the new york
times you know the one of the most
powerful political voices in american
politics is a guy named Marcus malicious
who started a website called daily coast
and every day he gets as many daily
readers as USA Today okay or you take
Pipo degree low in in Italy another
blogger who you know it has a huge
following so it's the media system has
become more open to new voices and those
voices that have to earn their
credibility with their readers in a new
way they don't get credibility because
they work for a giant corporation or
because they went to the right school
they get credibility because of what
they have to say and that resonates for
people and that's a challenge you know
the thing that we are experiencing the
United States with media political media
is we're seeing a hybrid develop where
because of the the pressure and the
competition from bloggers who are have
more of a real connection to their
readers the old media is adapting and
starting to use the same tools but in
the process when the New York Times
starts blogging and the Washington Post
starts blogging and they get lots and
lots of readers and lots and lots of
comments they have to interact right it
changes their journalism they come down
from the pedestal a little bit and mix
it up more with the crowd because it
turns out there are a lot of smart
people who read them and have something
good to say and so that is changing
journalism in a good way we're getting
something that I think is is like a
hybrid between the old you know sermon
of the powerful and the the new voice
from below